welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and with Netflix's
the spy now making its way worldwide
across the platform I thought I'd
examine the secret service series to
uncover everything that you need to know
about the events portrayed in it and its
ending there will be heavy spoilers here
so if you haven't had a chance to watch
the show yet then I highly recommend
that you turn off now without the way I
just want to give a huge thank you for
clicking this video now let's get into
my breakdown of the spy the spy centers
around Israel's top Mossad spy Elli
Cohen ironically played by Sacha Baron
Cohen Ali is an Egyptian Jew that was a
key player in smuggling Jewish people
out of Egypt but since then life has
become slightly mundane for him Ali
starts the show is a lowly typist in an
office often looked down upon by those
in our society but after being recruited
by the Israeli government he slowly
finds himself on a downward spiral that
sees the man losing his family life and
even identity Elly is a natural when it
comes to espionage and the character is
played expertly by Cohen who perfectly
portrays all of the nuances that lace
the performance with a subtlety that
makes Elly engaging methodical but also
dangerous even with a moustache that
should scream Borat two people Cohen
still completely avoids the stereotyping
and makes the role his own you can tell
that Cohen put a lot of work into this
and it's an authentic and believable
performance that beautifully showcases
the conflict of a man leading a double
life that is based on lies and mistrust
there's an air of Schindler's List about
the peace with a man using his charms to
integrate with society and it's clear
that Elly is very skilled at the
friending and manipulating people
initially the life of a spy seems
exciting and it's easy to relate to Elly
and see how much such a service would
seem attractive to a man who up until
this point has led a rather mundane life
he's fighting for the country that he
loves and a sense of danger that this
provides his throwing and exciting
especially with the amount of close
calls at Jerez but it puts a huge strain
on the relationship with his wife and
it's clear that Elly loses more than he
Ali even starts dating someone to keep
up the facade of his double life and
it's easy to see how he loses himself in
the role throughout the season we watch
his cohen builds relationships with
high-ranking syrian officials under the
identity of Kemal an importer and
exporter he builds up a large circle
around him made up of politicians
military officials and local authorities
and as things go on the situation's get
more and more extreme juxtaposing this
his relationship with his wife
completely disintegrates to the point
that when in character he's not even
allowed to acknowledge her after they
have a child together
Ali tries to stay but a sense of duty
calls her back he spies on several key
members and even a military installation
all with the purpose of building Intel
its a gripping watch and one that often
gets your heart pumping as you see Ali
slowly inch towards his eventual fate
when a bloody coup against the
government is staged which she's
instrumental in it becomes clear that
Elly may be in over his head
acting as a double agent has helped to
topple the government in order to
complete its mission Elli comes
face-to-face with the bin Laden's and a
young asama as he slowly works his way
up the ladder in the penultimate episode
but the shock slowly begin to circle him
suspecting there is a spy in their
organization Elli has trusted so much
he's even asked to be the new Deputy
Minister of Defence however that doesn't
mean that he's out of the woods just yet
and not long after being asked to join
his position he's soon discovered in
real life similar to the events in the
show the Syrians used tracking equipment
in order to capture any illegal
transmissions and they were able to
trace his signal to Cohen's apartment
where they pretty much caught him
red-handed sending messages in real life
Cohen did ask to leave the operation to
witness the birth of his third child
just before his eventual capture but
Israeli intelligence wanted him to
return to Syria once more which ended up
being his last visit for all the wrong
reasons
it's a heartbreaking element to the
story that really shows just how tragic
the entire ordeal was Elly is tortured
and interrogated and after being found
guilty of espionage a military tribunal
he's sentenced to death Israel did try
to get the spy freed through a campaign
of clemency but this fell on deaf ears
even with the intervention of primary
and the Pope Syria went ahead with the
execution and in his final letter Cohen
wrote I'm begging you my dear Nadia not
to spend your time in weeping about
something already past concentrate on
yourself looking forward for a better
future Elly was executed on the 18th of
May 1965 in Damascus but his legacy
lives on in the finale we see a moth fly
into a light bulb and die and this works
as a metaphor for the entire show like a
moth to the flame Cohen knew he was in
danger but he couldn't resist the lure
of power his ambition drove him and
allowed him to work his way up from a
lowly desk clerk to someone that was
considered for a huge position of power
he flew too close to the Sun however and
had a flower refused to return to the
country he would likely still be alive
today the government - do not come off
scot free in the show either and it
highlights just how expendable they view
those as they rely on the most we watch
in the finale that the government are
still trying to recruit spies and Ali
remains merely a statistic even though
he helped to establish the Intelligence
Agency more than they ever would have
been without him it's a really tragic
story and one that will stick with you
long after you finish watching it Cohen
has since become a national hero in
Israel with a large number of streets
carrying his name his family have been
visited by many prime ministers over the
AERS
and there currently exists a memorial
stone for him in the garden of missing
soldiers showcasing that though he may
be gone he is not forgotten Nadia to
this day is still trying to get his body
returned to Israel for a proper burial
but as of this video Syria have refused
and now on to my review I was really
spellbound throughout the spy and it's
grounded tragic tale is really
heartbreaking to watch play out
especially with just how likable Cohen
is as an actor it really shows what
people lose when they sacrifice and
things they love for their career and
Ali's story and legacy will no doubt
live on for a long time
due to the selfless work that it carried
out in his time as a spy
Netflix completely knocked it out of the
park with this one and it stands strong
with some of their best real life
adaptations such as mind hunter and more
The Spy is definitely the one to watch
this weekend and at only six episodes
it's an easy binge that will keep you
engaged from the beginning and
throughout I absolutely loved the spy
and can't recommend it highly
enough you need to watch this and that's
why it gets a 9 out of 10
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the spy and if you enjoyed it as much
as I did comment below and let me know
and if you enjoyed this video then
please like it and make sure you check
out my full breakdown of this weekend's
at the big release it chapter 2 which
will be linked at the end I go over
everything you need to know about the
movie and my interpretation of the
ending so it's definitely worth checking
out if you want to know more if you want
to come talk to me about movies TV shows
games and comic books then you can
follow me in Twitter definition YT it's
the best way to get in touch with me and
is the perfect place to suggest new
videos and content so hopefully I see
you over there after this well so just
one let you know that we're giving away
a free copy of John wick 3 and blu-ray
and all you have to do to be in with a
chance of winning is to like this video
make sure that you subscribe to the
channel and leave your thoughts on the
spy in the comment section below the
winner will be chosen at random on
September the 10th in the blue row be
shipped out from them to ever get
surprised it's the best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is the
channel for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]